[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
garantir l'accès de tous à l'Internet
très haut débit
le plan France très haut débit conduit
par l'État et les collectivités
territoriales en association avec les
opérateurs et industriels a permis de
rendre plus de 80 % des Français
raccordables à la fibre optique en 2022
néanmoins ce bilan positif esterni
depuis plusieurs années par des
problèmes survenants dans la réalisation
du raccordement final des abonnés de
nombreux souscripteurs font face à des
malfaçons à des débranchements
injustifiés ou encore à la dégradation
des infrastructures qui nuisent à la
qualité de ce nouveau réseau
ces désordres sont liés au choix de
confier la réalisation des raccordements
final au fournisseurs d'accès à Internet
qui ont souvent recours à une chaîne de
sous-traitance parce que la qualité du
déploiement de la fibre revient une
importance capitale pour les territoires
le Sénat c'est logiquement emparé de
cette question elle revêt un caractère
urgent car la fermeture du réseau cuivre
d'Orange est désormais imminente entre
2025 et 2030 en 2022 le sénateur Patrick
chaise a ainsi déposé une proposition de
loi dont le but est de fluidifier le
raccordement à la fibre optique sur
l'ensemble du territoire et de faciliter
les recours
le texte a été remanié et enrichi par la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire avant d'être adopté le 2 mai
2023 en séance publique il visa assurer
la qualité et la pérennité des réseaux
en fibre optique en clarifiant la chaîne
des responsabilités et en encadrant
véritablement les conditions de
réalisation des raccordements et le
contrôle de ses interventions la
proposition de loi prévoit de renforcer
également les pouvoirs de contrôle et de
sanctions de l'Autorité de régulation
des communications électroniques en
matière de qualité des raccordements des
utilisateurs final à la fibre optique
enfin elle vise à mieux protéger les
droits des usagers en cas d'interruption
prolongée du service d'accès à Internet
cela passe concrètement par la création
d'un droit à la suspension du paiement
de l'abonnement à l'indemnisation et à
la résiliation sans frais de
l'abonnement le texte est désormais
transmis à l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]